a very warm welcome to all our viewers
i'm angela from simply learned and today
you'll be learning what lists in python
are so we'll start with the basic
definition of what a list Asst will then
see how you can create the list we then
have accessing of the elements in the
list the various operations that can be
done on the list and then methods and
building functions specifically for
lists and finally we'll have a short
exercise using some of the concepts that
we learn today
so what Arliss a list is a collection of
data and this data could be of any data
type in fact a list could hold data of
different data types as we can see in
our example down here we have a list
named X and X wholes 189 the single
letter a the string hey another number 0
and a capital letter B now another
important factor with lists are it
indices every element in the list has a
position and this position is called an
index the first position in a list is
always 0 so 1 is at index 0 89 at index
1 a at index 2 and so on
so this means that the position of your
last element would be the length of your
list minus 1 so now that you know what a
list is let's move on to how you can
create a list so this is my Jupiter
notebook and we'll start by creating the
most basic list which is an integer list
so my list name would be num and then
open square brackets and within this
just put in your numbers separated by
commas
so that is my first list run this and
there seems to be no error
let's now print this list out just to
see what it looks like
and as you can see the elements that we
inserted in this list are printed which
are 1 2 3 & 4 next let's create a list
with just single characters
so my list name is letter and the syntax
is exactly the same you open square
bracket and now that we have letters
inside which are characters you type
these within codes
let's print this too and once again
after the run you can see the letters
that we inserted into our list letter
next let's create a list of strings so
I'll name my list STG open square braces
and again strings should always be
written within double or single quotes
and that's my list of strings at prin
this too great so now we have created a
list of only integers only letters and
only strings now as I mentioned before
lists can contain a combination of
different data types so let's try that
out I'll name my list mix because it's
going to be a mix of number strings to
numbers and then I'll follow this up
with a few strings
and let's run it so that works perfectly
fine now let's have another format if
you are worked with any other
programming language previously you
would have come across the term matrix
so usually in other programming
languages matrix are associated with
arrays so they are basically 2d arrays
in case of pythons matrix can also be of
lists so you can have a list containing
two or more lists so let's do that I'll
name my list mat as in short for matrix
open square braces and since the
elements of this list are also list put
these two in square braces
so our first list would be 1 comma 2 and
then comma because our second list is
basically the second element of our list
mat and the second list would be a B and
that's how you create a list containing
lists so a parent list is Matt and this
contains two lists the first list is 1
comma 2 and the second list is a comma B
so let's print this out and there you go
so we also created a list containing
lists so these are the different type of
list you can create next we will move on
to how you can access the elements
within this list so there's no point of
creating a list if you cannot access
each individual element within the list
now here to understand how to access the
elements of the list we'll be using the
list mix that we created previously
so before we start I'll just print out
mix so you can have an idea of what is
inside so we have 5 elements within mix
the first two are numbers or integers 1
comma 6 and that's followed up by three
strings simply learn get certified we
previously saw that every element in the
list has an index position so the
simplest way of accessing an individual
element in the list is by following the
list
with square braces and within the square
braces mention the index number of the
particular element so if I want to
access the element get my index would be
0 1 2 3 so mix of 3 and I'll run this we
got our element get now in a similar way
you can also use negative indices to
access the elements so when you put a
negative sign the indices are basically
counted from the back of the list now if
I want to access the same word yet but
all I know about this word position is
that it's a second last word in the list
I also do not know the length of the
list in this case I can just say mix of
minus 2 so 2 as in it's the second last
element and the minus signifies that you
count from the end of the list and not
from the beginning so I'll run this and
extract it get now as you probably would
have noticed in case of indices when
counted from the front of the list it
starts with 0 on the other hand when you
count the indices from the end of the
list
it starts with minus 1 and not zero so
now we saw how you can access a single
element from the front of the list and
from the back of the list now what if
you want to access a range of elements
say I want to extract the first three
elements of the list mix in that case I
could just type mix again square braces
and within here I'll put colons
followed by 3 so ideally there would be
a number on either side of the colon but
in this case we are taking from the
beginning of the list so if the digit
before the colon is supposed to be 0 you
can just leave it blank and
automatically it's interpreted as 0 also
we know that our third element would be
at the index position 2 but here we have
written index position 3 this is because
our last index positions always excluded
so if you give 2 instead of 3 then the
only elements that would be extracted
would be the ones at 0 with and first
position since we want the element
the second position - we give the ending
index as three
so let's print this and we received our
first three elements of the list mix
which are one six and the word simply
learn now what if we want to extract all
the elements from a certain position of
the list say our third index position of
the list up to the end of the list in
that case again we have mix square
braces and we have the same colons as we
used previously but now since we want
our starting index to be 3 we enter 3
and the element at the third index would
be included but now we want to extract
all elements to the end of the list so
you can just leave the last position
blank when you do this it's
automatically interpreted that you are
taking all the elements up to the end of
the list let's run this and received get
and certified now I want to extract the
words simply learn and get from our list
mix in this case what would be the
parameters within our square braces
so simply learn is at the index
recreation - and get is at the index
location 3 so our starting index would
be 2 but as we already mentioned
previously if I put 3 as my ending index
I would not receive the element at the
index position 3 therefore I'll put my
ending index as food and run this and
there you go we receive the two words
simply learn and get now here's
something slightly more fun so what if I
want to extract every second element of
my list in that case I put two double
colons followed by two because I want
every second element of my list and run
this so as you see here 1 has been
printed which is followed by 6 in our
list mix but 6 is skipped and then we
have simply learned again the word get
is skip and we have certified now
there's one more thing you can do with
list indices you can print them in the
reverse order so
to do that just two colons and -1
let's print that and as you can see your
list mix is printed in the reverse order
so now if we go back to line 16 these
two double colons are basically
positions for your indices so suppose
you want the second element from the
first index and not the 0th index you
can write one here and if you want every
second element from the first index up
to see the fifth index you can put five
here but in our case we do not have a
fifth index so I'll just leave it at
this
you can obviously try that out in fact
we'll be using a variation of this inner
exercise later on so now that we saw how
you can access the various elements of
the list let's look at the various
operations you can perform on the list
suppose you want to create a list of a
hundred zeros if we go by the
traditional methods we literally have to
type in a hundred zeros separated by
commas within the square braces and this
gets very tedious so a short way of
doing this is type in that one element
that you want repeated multiple times
within your list and outside the square
braces follow it up with Asterix digit
and the number of times you want this
element to be repeated so zero in 200
and let me print this and as you see a
hundred zeros exist within our list see
now we can also create a new list
concatenate in two or more less so let's
create a list concatenate in the two
lists that we previously created letter
and STG so I'll just print these lists
out first that's a list letter and
that's our list STG now we'll create a
new list calc on a short form for concat
and how do you concatenate two lists
well you just
add an addition sign between them so
letter plus STG and that's all it takes
to join two lists let's print out Kong
and there you go so the first four
elements in our list corn is from the
list letter and the last four elements
is from the list STG now there's another
operation with list call unpacking so
here you basically give a string as an
argument to this function list and that
unpacks each element of the string as a
separate element in the list so I'll
show you this with an example if I name
a list bad and list off within the
brackets I enter the string I say hey
there and now I'll print well so as you
can see every letter of this string hey
there has become a single element in the
list vad now let's check out another
operation on list using the list num
that we created previously so once again
I'll just print num out so we can recall
what was within it we had the four
numbers 1 2 3 4 now suppose I want the
first element of my list num which is 1
to be in a variable 1 and I want the
rest of the elements to be stored in
another list called say others how do I
do this I can just put 1 which is my
first variable a comma and then star
other equal to num so what happens here
is that the star signifies that every
element that has not been put into the
previous variable or variables is put
into this list other so let's print out
the variable 1 and the list others
separately and see what they contain and
as expected one contains the value 1
which is the 4
element of our list numb and the
following elements of our list which are
2 3 & 4 are stored in the list other
let's now look at a few methods best fit
your list so for the following few
examples we'll be using the list that we
created previously called num I'll print
the list out first sanam has the element
1 2 3 & 4 now the first method that
we'll be using is the append method and
the syntax for that is the list name
which is num dot append followed by
brackets and within these brackets you
basically insert the element that you
want to add to the end of your list
so suppose I want my list to be 1 2 3 4
6 all I do is enter 6 here and that
should ideally add 6 to the end of your
list numb so now let's print out num and
there you go so previously our lists
contain the numbers 1 2 3 4 and after we
executed the num dot append method 6 was
added to the end now what if we do not
want to add a single element to the end
of the list but an entire other list so
in this case we can use the method
extend the syntax for this is num dot
extend and within the brackets you'll
enter the name of the list you want to
add to your previous list so here I want
to add the list STG that we created
previously to the end of my list num now
before I execute this command let me
just print out STG so we know what's in
there so with an STD I have get
certified get ahead I'll just delete
this cell and now I'll run the command
so let's print out num and as you see
nom previously had 1 2 3 4 6 from here
and then we added get certified get
ahead to the end of this list now now
these kind of additions only take place
at the end of the list what if we want
to insert an element somewhere in
between the list for this we use the
method insert
and syntax is your list name num dot
insert and within brackets you first
enter the position or the index at which
you want to enter the new element so I
want to insert the string simply learn
just before get so this is my fifth
position
so my first parameter here would be five
followed by the element I want to enter
which is a string simply learn so I will
type it within quotes and let me run
that let's now see what num looks like
and as you see here we have one two
three four six and then we have the new
element that we just inserted simply
learn followed by the elements which
were previously in an STG list alone now
this another method you might come
across regularly which is the remove
method so this method as the name such
as removes a element it basically
removes the first occurrence of that
particular element so the syntax for
this is num dot remove and within the
brackets you enter the element that you
want to remove so I'll remove the
element simply learn and run let's now
see what num holds
so as you can see simply lawn has been
removed now if there were two
occurrences of simply learn one here and
maybe one after a head only this word
would be removed and not the one later
on because it removes only the first
occurrence of that particular word or
that particular element okay so now
let's create a new list say bad one and
we'll just insert a few letters in here
now imagine you receive a list like this
where there are few elements but in a
jumbled order you want to sort out this
list one simple method sort is all you
need to do bad or sort of run it and now
let's print out what one holds so all
your elements in Val 1 are now sorted
Python also provides a few built-in
functions that can be used with lists so
we'll have a look at the most basic ones
so before we begin let's create a list X
and I'll fill my list with just integers
so that's my list and we'll use this
list throughout all of built-in
functions now the most basic built-in
function and the most commonly used is
Len what Len does is it tells you the
length of your list so Len of X and the
length is 6 a next built-in function
that we'll try out is min min gives you
basically the minimum of all the
elements that's present in your list so
men of X and the minimum element in our
list is 4 similarly we also have max
which gives you the maximum of the
elements present in the list max of X
which is 90 now we also have a function
sum which basically gives you the sum of
all the elements present in your list so
sum of X and at 189 now in Python we do
not have a function which gives you the
average but it's very simple to
calculate this we do so using the sum
function so you find the sum and then
you divide that by the length of the
list so sum of X by Len of X would give
you the average of X so with that we
covered the basic built-in functions for
Python lists we also cover the methods
unless a few operations in lists we saw
how we can access the various elements
in list so for our exercise we need to
create a list of numbers from 1 to 10
we'll call this list 1 and then we'll
split list 1 into 2 lists odd which
contains all the odd elements of the
list 1 and even which contains all the
even elements of list 1 so now let's
move on to a Jupiter notebook and see
how this is done so let's first create
our list 1 which will contain all the
elements from 1 to 10 now you can use
the traditional methods and enter all
your numbers from 1 to 10 within these
square braces separated by commas or we
look at a simpler way of doing this to
say list and to this you pass the
function range and within range you
specify the range of the
element you want within list1 so I want
all the elements from one up to ten so
my ending index would be 11 and they are
separated by commas let's run this and
let's print list one and there you go so
all your digits from 1 to 10 is stored
within list 1 now the next thing we need
to do is as I mentioned earlier we need
to split list 1 into odd and even and
odd list will contain all the odd
elements and even will contain all the
even elements so let's start with odd
so my list name is odd and the elements
will be taken from list 1 and now the
tricky part how do we specify the
indices in this case so if you remember
previously we had gone through an
example where we want to access every
second element in which case our index
was mentioned like this where the two
indicated that every second element
would be taken from the list so in this
case two since odd numbers occur after
every second element our interval is
still 2 and we'll start from the 0th
position of the list which is 1 and go
up to the end so this is a command let's
see what odd holes
and as you can see all has all the odd
numbers from list one now we need to
store all the even numbers from list one
into this list even
again our interval would be two but this
time if we just skip every second
element from the beginning even would
have all the odd numbers so what we do
is we'll start skipping the second
element from our second element so from
index 1 onwards we'll start skipping
every second element let's print out
even
and there you go so a list even has the
even numbers 2 4 6 8 and 10 so with that
we successfully completed our exercise
and we also come to an end to list in
Python if you have any doubts please
post them in the comment section below
and we'll definitely get back to you
please hit the like button if you like
the video also subscribe to our channel
as we have a lot more coming up
this is anjali signing off see y'all
next time
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here